the following video was filmed during
the 2023 wga and sag after strikes
without the labor of the writers and
actors currently striking The Works
being covered here wouldn't exist I
fully support both the wga and sagaftra
in their fight for fair treatment and
compensation against a system that
continually denies them such while
sag-aftra has asked that creators such
as myself refrain from anything that
constitutes promotion of work from
struck Studios they have made allowances
for the creation of analytical critique
and review as these do not constitute
promotion of the work but instead
critical assessment of art any praise I
give to these Works should be purely
seen as praise for the artists writers
and actors who created them and any
criticism that ASU should not be taken
as meaning that I believe they do not
deserve full and fair compensation I
will continue to do my best to support
the unions as the strike continues thank
you
I do not have nearly as much pink in my
wardrobe as you might think I would
maybe I'm wearing some pink on the
bottom half you don't know
foreign
[Music]
late to the party
talking about what is at time of
recording the biggest most successful
movie of the year
Barbie has now beaten the Super Mario
Brothers movie as the highest grossing
film released in 2023 and it is unlikely
to be topped by any of the things
remaining to come out this year this is
the biggest movie to come out this year
it is released by Major studio is a
massive brand but it's also
very subversive particularly about the
brand that it is ostensibly an extension
of
co-written and directed by Greta Gerwig
Barbie Dives pretty deep into a lot of
philosophical existential fears and
concerns and ideas about Barbie's place
in the world for Better or For Worse it
delves into patriarchy ultimately
landing on the fact that it is just as
damaging to men as it is women even
though they think they benefit from it
it is a movie that has infuriated the
right been embraced by a large portion
of the left has been hailed as a
subversively feminist film and and
insightful and incisive one at that
so why didn't I like it nearly as much
as pretty much everyone I know yeah
that's uh
that's what that's what this is about
this is about now before I get into this
and I go down this rabbit hole
I want to be clear on something
I think Barbie's a good movie
I think might even be a great movie I
get why Everyone likes it I don't think
anyone's wrong and I don't think anybody
is missing something or that like I've
cracked the code of the secret problems
with Barbie I think even some of the
stuff that I'm gonna point out has been
noted by some people and in some cases
was noted within the film itself but it
still landed not quite right with me
for one reason that is not the movie's
fault
and then the reason that kind of is at
least a little bit the movie's fault and
that's the one I'm gonna spend a heck of
a lot more time dealing with but also
even with that second one I get why it
hasn't hit everybody's being a issue
with the movie whereas it did me here's
the thing that's not the movie's fault
at uh a lot of it had been spoiled for
me not like plot wise I'm it's got the
kind of plot that I don't think is
really especially spoilable it's not
really a plot Driven movie All Things
Considered but it is a comedy
and a lot of the bits the jokes the
setups they had been spoiled for me
let's off anyone who wants to beat
him off has to pitch me off first I will
beat both of you off at the same time
either in the trailers or just people
who I knew who had seen it who wanted to
talk about certain bits you know when I
was in the room or even tell me about
them or just you know osmosis through
social media just catching a lot of
stuff and as a result there was not a
lot in the movie that surprised me now
surprise is not the only component of
humor and certainly there are many good
movies that should be very very good
even if you know what's gonna happen in
them but the thing is knowing in advance
what's going to be in it I think hurts
comedies more than others because while
surprise is not the only component of
humor it is a big one in most cases a
lot of times what gets you to laugh at
least initially at something is the
shock of it I'm not saying necessarily
shock talk humor but I'm saying like
that went in a direction I didn't expect
that person said something I wasn't
expecting they worded that in a way I
didn't think was going to happen didn't
see that coming
and
I did see most of it coming
I knew most of what was in this
and that
I was gonna say probably no that
definitely hampered the experience at
least a little bit for me
and the way I know for a fact that that
was at least a contributing factor in my
not quite feeling as positive on this as
others uh is because the I can nail down
two things they're not the only two
things but like two things in particular
that stood out to me is positives
um were things that I didn't really know
too much about in advance one was
America Ferreira like I knew she was in
the movie but I didn't know a ton about
her part and I ended up liking her a lot
and I don't think that's only because I
didn't know as much about her but you
know
I'd seen all the praise from Margot
Robbie and for Ryan Gosling I I'd seen
all that I'd seen the clips they're good
they're great in their respective Parts
I hadn't seen nearly as much of America
Ferreira so she was able to surprise me
like side note she's not getting nearly
as much praise as she should be for this
do you know how hard it is to be saddled
with a character who has to literally
spit out the themes of the movie and
have that land well and not come across
as awkward and clunky and forced and she
Nails it
like come on I'm not saying that she was
better than Margot Robia that she was
better than Ryan Gosling or that she was
better than Will Ferrell okay no
actually I am gonna say she was better
than Will Ferrell but
you know I didn't know as much about her
part going in and I liked her a lot more
as a result of that and the other thing
is the literally last line last joke of
the movie was the one that got the
biggest vocalized laugh out of me
because
who caught me off guard
like big time caught me off guard that
one
and I laughed a lot harder not because
it was a better joke
but because I didn't see it coming
and so that's one factor and that has
nothing to do really with the movie
itself there's nothing to analyze about
that I kind of had some of the jokes
maybe a lot of the jokes spoiled or at
least the premises and concepts of them
so it couldn't surprise me too much with
where it went so
that's really nothing to analyze there
's the other thing
the thing that
sat in the back of my head
and even after
hearing people talk about it talk about
the feminist themes the empowerment
themes the positivity themes of it and
seeing that analysis hearing it agreeing
with it
but still not feeling quite right about
it that took a little more time to have
to think about
so there's an aspect of the film that I
think landed very well for other people
but kind of soured for me
as time went on the more I thought about
it I think it landed well for other
people because
they're not burnt out on it yet
this has to do with the examination and
criticism of Barbie itself
by the movie Barbie because this film is
examining the impact that Barbie has on
culture now that's not the only thing
it's doing as I said it's it's doing a
take down a patriarchy it's doing some
of the things too but it is taking the
time to examine and comment on and
criticize
the place that Barbie holds in culture
and I think that endeared a lot of
people to this movie
and it didn't work on me
the thing is it didn't work on me
because I know why they did it
and I know too much about
why this was allowed to happen and I've
been seeing it too much lately
this is
a very effective trick
for a little while
the acknowledging of one's own faults
and especially coming from something as
protective of itself as a brand like
Barbie is multiple characters point out
the harm that Barbie has laid out and
that's part of Barbie's own existential
crisis is realizing that not everyone
thinks she's amazing and awesome and
incredible and realizing why they think
that and feeling that seep into her
I've seen this trick done too many times
though and the thing is I know it's
effective
when you're not immune to it when you
haven't been inoculated to it when it
doesn't feel like you've developed a
natural immunity
because the first time I remember seeing
this
whole thing pulled was in a much smaller
moment and this I'm not saying this was
the first time but it's the first one I
remember I think this started my
becoming aware of it
was in The Matrix resurrections which is
a much better movie than y'all seem to
have collectively decided it is by the
way but anyways there's a bit very early
on where canonically within the film
Keanu Reeves is playing the creator of
the Matrix trilogy in Universe it's a
video game Trilogy instead of film
Trilogy I'm sure you can understand why
our beloved parent company Warner
Brothers has decided to make a sequel to
the trilogy one they informed me they're
going to do it with or without us and
the thing is
that's basically what happened to Lana
Wachowski who directed that movie
it was gonna happen whether she held it
or not I was kind of impressed at that
that it got called out in specific like
the general setup was already a little
bit
but what made me feel like oh you got
away with something you slipped
something under the radar there was the
fact that she named Warner Brothers
I was shocked that she got away with
that that they let her do that
and I'm pretty sure I even singled out
that moment when I did my review of the
movie
but
then I kept seeing it again
next time I saw it was in the finale of
She-Hulk
She-Hulk is a show I'm a bit mixed on
but I do think it's last three episodes
or so are by far the strongest stuff
that it has
and in its final episode it Embraces a
meta nature and has She-Hulk actually go
to the Disney offices and confront
Kevin now the inherent implication and
assumption is that this is Kevin feige
the producer and sort of Overlord of the
MCU said it turns out Kevin is an AI
Kevin's a computer it stands for
knowledge enhanced visual
interconnectivity nessus deciding what
is the best course of action by
algorithm and by data and
that's
pretty searing to imply that the
direction of the biggest franchise going
right now in the entire world is just
being run by a machine
now part of me was a little bit
disappointed and did think wouldn't it
be more in size to Vivi I actually had
the guy there
um and you know maybe they decided it
wasn't worth doing maybe he didn't want
to do it maybe he wasn't comfortable
with somebody impersonating him or maybe
they
um just decided that this was a better
way to go about it I think even a little
bit more
incisive to actually hold the people the
actual people responsible a little bit
rather than make a joke out of it except
it is also kind of incisive to imply
that the decisions might as well be a
machine because that's what they come
across like which is the point I myself
have made in some recent videos so still
works part of the reason that one still
got away with it for me is also because
it's She-Hulk and if you've read as much
She-Hulk as I have
the series tends to do this you can look
at John Byrne's stuff in the late 80s
and it was not uncommon at all for she
hoped to literally address the writer
and call him on some BS but it also
didn't catch me as off guard and I liked
it as I said it was the better stuff of
that show
but I think that's where I started to
hit a natural immunization to this
technique so that when we get to Barbie
and we get to its acknowledgment of
the brand as potentially damaging
potentially uh creating a harmful
standard of being run by uh corporate
buffoons who don't have the best of
intentions
I don't find charm in it
anymore
because once is a fluke twice is a trend
three times that's a pattern
and patterns like this in Hollywood in
big budget filmmaking don't happen by
accident they happen because they are
allowed to and I don't doubt that there
are many people who watch Barbie and
felt like they had the experience of
seeing what a Creator got away with do
you believe Greta Gerwig got away with
doing this much criticism of Barbie the
doll and the brand in a movie about
Barbie how'd you get away with it she
didn't get away with it they let her do
it
they knew what she was going to do now I
want to be real clear about this Reddit
Gerwig
is not a hack she's not a shill and I
don't think that she has any devious
machinations behind what it was she
wanted to do I think she very much made
the movie she wanted to make and said
the things she wanted to say with it
sincerely
that having been said
it wasn't snuck under the noses of the
suits there were people at two massive
corporations who had to sign off on this
Warner Brothers and Mattel she didn't
sneak it by them
they signed off on it
so however subversive the film may feel
it is allowed into theaters in the state
that it is with the full awareness and a
massive marketing push from both the
corporate entities behind it so
I feel like you know what I'm gonna make
a comparison and this is a comparison
that's either gonna snap into place
exactly what I'm talking about
or it's going to leave you wondering
what the hell I'm on about hopefully
it'll work we'll see
remember five or six years ago
when the Wendy's official Twitter
account started like trolling people
slagging off other brands in the replies
to tweets by those other brands and
getting into fights in its own in its
own comment sections with other users
the when the Twitter account the Bland
corporate official back when the blue
check mark meant something and you
couldn't just pay for it official
corporate account for Wendy's started
acting like a person
and a kind of unhinged person at that
you remember how exciting that was how
it felt like
corporate doesn't know they must not
know they're not keeping on top of this
there's no way that they can know what
whoever's running the Twitter account is
doing they wouldn't let it let them get
away with this and in addition to what
the Wendy's account was doing being
funny that added to it because you felt
like you were in on something you were
watching somebody get away with
something
it was exciting
and then every other corporate account
started doing it they all got sassy
they all got cute
they all tried to jump in on trending
topics they all tried to post as if they
were people instead of corporate
accounts and by the fourth fifth sixth
twelfth of these things you realize oh
oh it's not an issue of corporate
doesn't realize what's going on they're
letting it happen
because it helps their bottom line
it can appear to be subversive and
against the interest of the company and
who wait till they get caught they're
gonna get in so much trouble
it's not a question of getting caught
maybe when Wendy's did and Wendy's might
not have even been the first that was
just the one that I remember blowing up
first maybe when Wendy's first started
doing it maybe it was a little bit of a
daring thing to do
but
everyone that came after that
no they knew exactly what they were
doing
and over time with each new one you're
like oh yeah there's another corporate
account being cute and sassy yeah yeah
we see through this now we know what
you're doing it's not cute anymore
that was my experience
of watching the Barbie movie whereas I
feel like most other people's experience
of watching the Barbie movie was like
finding the Wendy's Twitter account for
me it was like finding the 12th Wendy's
Twitter account knockoff
that's what it felt like
so rather than just leave this as like a
general impression I am going to go over
some specifics within the movie that
really have solidified this feeling for
me that have kind of
sour beyond the film overall and again
I'm going to reiterate right now I don't
think it's a bad movie I don't think
Reddit girl wig's a hack I don't think
she's a shill I don't think she was
secretly
um being manipulated by the executives I
think she made exactly the movie she
wanted to make it's connecting with a
lot of people it's lending with a lot of
people they love it they like it younger
audiences are getting introduced to
these ideas of anti-patriarchy and
feminism and the importance of
positivity like all these are good
things
that were not my experience of the movie
I can only speak from the perspective I
have I'm not going through these to
convince you that Barbie is not good
actually I do think Barbie is good
I just did not get to have the same
experience and that's what I'm talking
about and I am now going to get into
some specifics as to why
the first thing
is the corporate characters
they honestly really rubbed me the wrong
way
wrong some people have cited them as
being a problem because they're
cartoonish like the fact that the
offices have these cubicles that
literally have no way in and out so like
it's clearly an exaggeration despite the
fact that it's supposed to be the quote
unquote real world and it seems just as
cartoonish as Barbie world does in a lot
of ways that's not my problem
I think that's fine I think bending the
realism to make your thematic uh point
and also kind of making the Point
corporate culture is just as artificial
and warped as Barbie land is no that is
totally valid you can do that that's
fine that's not my problem
my problem is that
it feels
like criticism it feels
like
poking at people who deserve it
but it's actually making them seem
harmless
because you have Will Ferrell who I
don't really like in most things and
didn't really like him in this and I
think they let him improv too much and I
think they let too much of that improv
stand because everybody laughed on the
set on the day I think his scene should
have been cut by half but regardless
even if he nailed it and I wasn't
bothered by him ultimately what are
these doing
you might think oh wow the executives at
Mattel let themselves be depicted as
selfish buffoonish foolish ignorant
overly money focused woo
surprised they they let Greta go away do
that I'm not you know why because you
know what else it makes them look like
harmless
because the executives aren't the
villain there isn't really a well
patriarchy is the villain but
there isn't a a character villain in the
movie then that in and of itself is fine
but you have these stand-ins for the
suits and yes they're poked fun at yes
they're laughed at
they also remain in the same positions
that they were in before they are
treated as at worst foolish a little
ignorant and maybe a little selfish they
don't mean anything by it though
they don't mean to do bad things they're
just not realizing or you know they need
to learn they need to be taught I'm not
comfortable
with the heads of major corporations
like Mattel being depicted uh as
harmless
because they're not their decisions and
the way that they affect lives of their
employees and the lives of other people
in the world are massive
responsibilities
and if they are going to be depicted as
buffoonish
then they should be removed from those
positions
it shouldn't be left there
that shouldn't be treated as just okay
or are we all just like okay with this
that's kind of what I mean when I say
that there is the cloud of corporate
approval on this
because I'm not going to claim that
there was an earlier version of the
script where the uh CEO and the other uh
people in that office and in that board
room you know were more maliciously evil
and they were you know jailed or lost
their jobs I'm not claiming that there
was an early version of the script that
did that but I am going to say that if
there was
this would have been the compromise
you can make fun but you can't make them
the villains
another moment that kind of sums it up
really really well
is a moment later on
where Barbie is just very overwhelmed by
everything going on he talks about how
she doesn't feel pretty
and the narrator who is established and
has been a part of the movie in
voiceover says a note to the filmmakers
Margot Roby is not the person who should
be delivering this message
let's set aside for a moment the fact
that uh people considered classically or
traditionally or idealized way beautiful
I still have every right to feel like
they aren't pretty but the point is not
invalid because that's usually the kind
of person who is delivering this message
in Hollywood so while it's perfectly
valid for someone that most people would
say is by most measures a beautiful
person they are still allowed to feel
bad that is the way that this tends to
get presented regardless so it's not an
invalid point
foreign
but the movie still does it
they point out that it's not really okay
but it's also still there
and more to the point the narrator that
points us out is Helen Mirren
Helen Mirren
is famously one of the most lasting
Beauties in all of Cinema she has
retained an accepted level of beauty
through ages where most people would be
considered too old to be considered
beautiful
so not only
is arguably the actress saying the line
within movie the wrong person delivered
the message
ah so's the narrator pointing it out
and also
you still did it
to quote Yahtzee croshaw if you know
it's bad why are you doing it and again
that very much carries the flavor
of the corporate approval of of the
supposed subversion
corporations like Warner Brothers like
Mattel
they know it's good for business
if they seem like they have a sense of
humor about themselves or
if it seems like they let creative minds
do what they're going to do even if it
includes criticizing them that is good
for their image
I don't want their image to be good
I don't want people to come out of this
thinking well of Mattel
or Warner Brothers
but the fact that people seem to take
this movie and very much that oh do you
believe they got away with that oh they
didn't get away with it they were
allowed to do it
because the final product that hit the
theaters was viewed by both corporate
entities as being a net positive for
them does that mean 100
devoid of criticism for either of them
no no it doesn't
but they wouldn't have let it out the
door if they thought the criticism was
harsher than whatever the returns were
going to be either Financial or in terms
of Goodwill so you have things like in
the boardroom words point out everyone
in there is a man
that's a real valid point in its Decades
of existence Mattel has had two female
CEOs the first one wasn't until the 90s
the second one wasn't until the late
2010s
it's a legitimate criticism
that a brand that so much of its
marketing power is in marketing to women
and girls does not have any interest in
empowering
people of that same gender identity into
actual positions of power within the
company that's a legitimate problem
and they made it a joke
and that's the thing like you can say to
me and not be wrong that Within These
jokes they are pointing out actual
issues you know issues of Barbie's uh
image issues of uh too many men in
Industry issues of who gets allowed to
have a voice in discussions of bodies
and body positivity
yeah
these are all legitimate points but the
thing is none of these things none of
these problems are funny
I feel like the only time they are
allowed to come up especially when it is
in opposition to a standard corporate
mandate or through line or message
is when they're delivered
couched in humor see we can laugh at
ourselves I don't want you to laugh at
yourself I want you to change what
you're doing
I don't want Mattel to go boardroom of
all men I want you to fix the problem
I don't want a movie to go Margot Robbie
is the wrong person to give this message
I want it to address that problem not
just point it out
because just continuing to do the same
thing while pointing out that it's not
good
that's not endearing to me for very long
I have reached a point in my life where
I don't actually think very highly of
self-deprecation as a thing something I
try and do less in my own life because
you know it can be a way to seem more
human more approachable
etc etc
ultimately though I think it's not good
for a lot of people's ego when you do it
too much but the thing is people
certainly have a right to self-deprecate
I've done it before
I don't want businesses to
self-deprecate I don't want corporations
to self-deprecate because you're not a
person
regardless of what the legal definition
is regardless of the nonsense that is
Corporate personhood in regards to the
fact that money is somehow speech
you're not a person you're a company
and so when you make fun of yourself
it's not endearing
it's not cute
it's manipulation
it's a way to act like you deserve the
kind of benefit of the doubt that a
human being would get when you're a
corporate entity that is harming
the planet
Society
any number of things
I don't want to see you encouraging me
to laugh at you I will laugh at you
but not on your terms
I don't want to laugh at the jokes you
allow to happen about you
if I'm gonna laugh at Corporate America
or add to the unrealistic beauty
standards I'm gonna do it with people
who aren't a part of that system
because the oh we're all friends here
see I can laugh at myself
unless you're actually going to change
your behavior or to go along with that
laughter I don't care
and this in tone has gotten a little bit
more spiteful and a little more bitter
than I want and I want to be clear that
bitterness is not directed at the film
that bitterness is directed at the
corporate entities who are going to try
and Bank Goodwill off this and they're
not going to get very much we're
probably going to see them do what
corporate entities almost always do
which is to completely miss the point
and not understand why this is such a
hit and we're going to get things like a
Polly Pocket movie
um because they just think this means
people want doll movies that's the
bizarre thing about corporate thinking
on the one hand they are aware that
Greta Gerwig was making fun of them and
they signed off on it because they
believe they can benefit from it they
are smart enough to do that yet at the
same time they are foolish enough to
think that if they just Cobble together
the most superficial aspects of Barbie
and do it again they'll get the same
success again so they're gonna throw
together other Mattel based movies that
are just going to be big on pastel
colors and and slightly risque humor
and they think they'll get the same
result
they can recognize that a piece of art
because Barbie is art
and I don't just mean that because you
know it's all art no I mean like it is a
work of art
they can see the way that can benefit
them it doesn't mean that they actually
understand what went into its creation
would allow it to happen again
especially when they think they can
break it down into its component pieces
reassemble it and have something just as
good
so the bitterness you're hearing from me
it's not directed at Margot Robbie Ryan
Gosling Greta Gerwig Noah bombach any of
the people involved at the granular
level with the movie
it's directed at Warner Brothers and
it's directed at Mattel
I don't like it
when corporate entities of that size
because corporate entities of that size
are inherently damaging
to the free market well the free market
what a lie that is to the market
to the environment to society they're
just bad they're bad across the board
don't try to endear yourself to me I
will resent you for it
and
this is something that is probably going
to be a criticism that is going to pop
up for other things
it didn't really pop up for the MCU with
She-Hulk they kind of got away with that
again a little bit unprecedent because
She-Hulk as a character has done that
before they try and pull that again I'm
probably gonna resent them for it
if I uh if I feel like Star Wars is
doing it I might resent them for it
Disney as a whole I definitely kind of
have started to resent for it as I get
deeper into my 40s
I am tired
and I am fed up
and I am
immune to the charm
of these tricks and maybe part of the
reason I was willing to believe that the
Matrix resurrections really did sneak
that in under the radar was because it
was just it was just one moment but when
it's this chord of the film
no
that went through too many approval
levels went through too many layers at
two different massive corporations they
knew
they knew it was critical of Barbie and
of them
they let it go out anyways because they
think it's good for them
and
while again I do not feel that reflects
badly on any of the artists who actually
made it
um it does still make me not as
embracing of the product
I'm not trying to stomp on anybody's
good time but Barbie it's actually been
really wonderful for me to see how much
people love it
to see the reasons that they love it
because the reasons that they love it
are wonderful to see and hear and read
it just
wasn't going to work on me
and I had to talk about why
and if I've ruined it for you I'm
actually kind of sorry
or if you think that I have completely
overstepped and gone too harsh
oh maybe I don't know
but whatever your thoughts are
on my issues with what my experience of
Barbie was
and my issues with the
shadow of corporate approval that I felt
hanging over it and that other people
either didn't notice or aren't bothered
by whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it patreon pays the bills if
I didn't completely take you off
consider helping me continue to do this
as my living but
um don't worry too much about that
there's other stuff that you can follow
or check out from me that are down in
the description check out the fun to
help the Striking unions we support them
here but what I really want you to
remember
you are beautiful
you are valid
and you are loved
you are the council I'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
Council
is adjourned
[Music]
a special thanks to my highest
supporting patrons Robin Moore Zubin
lipfula Tara the thing that goes Oink in
the anime Ruth Oliver B solitary
pictures old Greg Bogdan Melinda Walters
Jen Auntie Kate 808 Becky Sparks and
I'll be likes the poodle Robin Powell
traces rabbit angry Casper Adam RDO
Taylor Dave Hall and Rosalind Ben you'll
see a bunch of other names down there as
well there's plenty of things to get on
the patreon and yeah you can hear me
attempt to say your name without
embarrassing myself check out the
rewards and thank you for everyone who
supports this
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]